C'est bon mes parents se sont enfin lassés de dire "Face de book".
Maintenant ils disent "Amstramgram".
Trop des barres maman, je veux mourir, tuez-moi.
Mes parents ont quand même progressé en technologie
maintenant ils savent ce que c'est un bureau, un copier-coller, une fenêtre.
Maintenant que Snapchat est sorti on repart à zéro.
- Oui maman ?
- Comment je fais pour avoir la tête de chien comme toi ?
Ah oui le filtre Snapchat, ok... T'es sur Snapchat là ?
- C'est le jaune ?
- Ouais voilà, tu vois ton visage ?
- Oui oui.
- Ok, maintenant tu restes appuyé sur ton visage.
Et tu glisses sur la droite jusqu'à ce que tu vois le chien.
oh bah oui ! Je vois le chien !
Voilà, bisous.
Ouais ma mère est sur Snapchat, ouais...
En fait elle est absolument partout
Le pire c'est quand elle essaye de poster un commentaire sur Facebook
Sous une photo de moi en vacances elle laisse :
"C'est bon j'ai retrouvé ton carnet de santé"
Et bien sûr, tous mes potes qui lui répondent pour bien me foutre la honte
Non maman : "J'espère que tu as passé de bonnes vacances"
Ça c'est un commentaire Facebook
"Passe prendre le pain" Ça n'a rien à faire sur mon mur !
c'est un SMS ça !
Et en parlant de commentaires la dernière fois, elle m'a fait la meilleure
T'as pas répondu à mon commentaire...
Quel commentaire ? T'as posté ça où ?
Sur Youtube, sous ta dernière vidéo
Maman, j'ai plus de dix milles commentaires sous mes vidéos, t'es au courant de ça ?
Ah bah d'accord, c'est comme ça que tu traites ta mère !
Mais nan maman, sur Youtube...
J'aurais dû demander des pouces bleus...
Quoi ?
Ma mère m'a ajouté sur tous les réseaux sociaux
Il n'en manque pas un. Y'a pas un réseau social où je suis tranquille.
J'ai l'impression qu'en fait, elle peut sévir à tout moment comme ça
Mettre un like ou un commentaire
- On fait une photo ?
- Allez ! Ouais !
*Photo*
Poste-la sur Amstramgram, j'te mettrai un commentaire...
AAAAAAAAAAH
Bon, mes parents galèrent un petit peu avec la technologie
Mais c'est rien à côté de mes grands-parents !
Là on atteint des sommets, c'est artistique quoi
La dernière fois ma grand-mère a essayé de me prendre en photo avec mon propre téléphone
Moment culte
- Ah si si !
- Non non mamie...
- T'inquiète pas !
- J'vais le faire... c'est un selfie...
- Mais si t'inquiète pas
- Non ça ne va pas marcher comme ça
Le pire, c'est qu'elle a réussi à prendre la photo
Comment t'as fait ça ?
*Photo*
Sans le faire exprès avec son nez !
Ta mamie elle s'y connaît
Ah ouais ça marche
Hop là, je t'ai pris en photo
Alors depuis peu, elle a son propre smartphone
Mais ce qu'elle ne sait pas c'est qu'elle appelle tout le temps en FaceTime
Mamie t'es en vidéo là.
- Mais j'ai un nouveau téléphone, merci, merci pour le cadeau !
- Oui, mais je parle à une oreille tu comprends ça ?
Après des heures de discussion avec une oreille, elle a enfin compris qu'elle était en vidéo
Et maintenant... Je parle à un front.
- C'est bon là ? Moi je te vois bien
- C'est un peu mieux
Voilà. Alors ça c'est le cadrage typique des vieux ça.
Je me rends compte que les vieux n'utilisent pas la technologie de la même manière que nous
Dans le téléphone de ma grand-mère
Il y a le Bridge.
On s'est tous cotisés pour lui offrir un téléphone à 500 balles
Elle peut jouer à ses jeux en 3D, des jeux de stratégie, au Nope Quiz
Téléchargez-le gratuitement (#Publicité)
Mais non, elle joue à un jeu de cartes
Et quand je vois les nouveaux trucs qui sortent
Par exemple les écouteurs sans fils (180 balles merci Apple)
J'me dis ma grand-mère elle doit être totalement paumée, elle doit rien comprendre
- Qu'est-ce que tu cherches ?
Mes écouteurs, ils étaient là ...
Oh c'est bon, c'est bon je m'en suis occupé.
De mes écouteurs ?
Ils étaient cassés...
Ils n'avaient plus de fils, je les ai jetés
T'as jeté mes écouteurs ?!
Oh, c'est fragile ces trucs là ...Les fils qui cassent...
C'est dommage !
T'as jeté mes écouteurs mamie ?
180 balles !!
Ma grand-mère il lui a fallu deux mois pour installer sa box internet
Elle était totalement paumée c'était impossible pour elle
Entre les prises téléphoniques, les box, les CPL, les câbles ethernet et tout ça
Elle était paumée !
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée de soutien pour ceux qui travaillent
dans les centres d'appels du service après-vente pour les box internet
Avec les vieux qui appellent là, courage les gars...
Ok, ça va bien se passer, ça va être mieux qu'hier...
Je vais avoir que des jeunes...
Oh putain, ça commence...
- Oui monsieur Lucien, on va reprendre depuis le début...
Est-ce que votre câble d'alimentation est bien branché ?
OK... Je peux le faire...
Oui bonjour en quoi puis-je vous aider ?
"Bonjour, ma box elle ne marche pas je comprends rien"
Bon je suis un peu dur avec les vieux c'est vrai,
pour une fois on peut leur apprendre quelque chose
C'est une passation de connaissance, c'est beau quand même
Merci d'être passé, et merci de m'avoir expliqué pour mon téléphone
Ça c'est rien mamie
Attends, fait voir ?
Ils ont comme même quelque chose dont on rêve tous
Il te reste 90% de batterie ?
Il est 16h, la chance !
Oui. Si tu m'appelais plus souvent, même un SMS
peut-être que j'aurais moins de batterie
T'as raison mamie.
Promis je t'appellerai.
À bientôt.
Il a cru quoi lui !
90% à 16 heure, il est fou !
Allez, le Bridge !
Abonne-toi !